good afternoon everyone
my name is Ian lap I'm the associate
dean for academic affairs and education
here at the Melbourne School of Public
Health at Columbia University and on
behalf of our Dean Lynda P freed we are
delighted to co-sponsor this magnificent
event as I was just saying to dr. Lipman
it's actually quite appropriate that
this event could be housed in the the
Rosenfield building the home of the
mailman school because public health is
inherently an interdisciplinary field
and in many ways embodies all of all
four schools here up at the Medical
Center in a rather rich and robust
manner and we like the other schools
here have benefited immensely from
PubMed and all the work that dr.
Lippman's group has done here I know dr.
Lipman as many ways the celebrity of
sorts he may not think of himself as
such but I think within this audience
you're most definitely a celebrity and
but it does bear introducing him
appropriately dr. Lipman is the director
of the National Center for Biotechnology
information known as NCBI as you know
and it's a major research and
development division of the National
Library of Medicine within the NIH he
was appointed as their first director in
1989 shortly after congress created the
center in 1988 he has overseen its
growth which has been a phenomenal
growth i may add into one of the most
heavily used resources in the world for
the search and retrieval biomedical
information with about it's a staggering
number two million users each day ncbi
has a leadership role of conducting
basic research in computational
molecular biology and in storing
annotating and making accessible
biomedical information and genetic data
emanating for research conduct at NIH
and laboratories around the world
dr. Lipman is a native New Yorker
actually from Rochester he received his
BA in biology from Brown University and
his MD degree right here in New York
State from state university of new york
at buffalo after his medical training
dr. Lipman joined the mathematical
research branch of the National
Institute of Diabetes digestive and
kidney disease as an NIH research fellow
he study molecular evolution and
developing computational tools for
sequencing comparison dr. Lipman is one
of the developers of the original blast
which is the basic local alignment
search tool algorithm for rapidly
identifying biological sequences that
are similar to a query sequence dr.
Lipman as you all know is a recipient of
numerous awards as an elected member of
the National Academy of Sciences the
Institute of Medicine the american
academy of arts and sciences and the
american college of medical informatics
without further ado I welcome dr. Lipman
to the stage I apologize ahead of time I
cannot stay for the talk but it does
allow me to remind you that this is
being videotaped so when you do ask
questions a little later if you'll come
up to the mic that'll be wonderful and I
look forward to watching the video tape
of this so dr. Lipman take it away thank
you I just
yes okay well thanks and it really is a
pleasure to be able to come I especially
a pleasure to come when I don't have to
deal with all the snow that caused a
cancellation the previous attempt at
this it might be useful it's not a big
group to get a sense of what the
backgrounds of some of y'all are so that
i can i can show the same slides but but
sort of cover different areas so how
many folks are more from the information
science library a library area here okay
and how many are researchers
experimentalists okay and some are
publishers now you can go now that's a
joke oh you're okay you're okay say
hello to Mike for me huh okay all right
so this is taken from Harold Varmus book
the art and politics of science and and
really shows that the notion that
communicating and sharing knowledge has
really been a really important part of
academics and research for for many many
years and if we're looking sort of in a
more the modern period the evolution
towards towards resources like PubMed
Central see that in the early 80s there
was a huge investment nit around the
country that made it possible for many
people to have access to computers on
their desktop access to internet and so
forth we've actually spent you know
hundreds of billions of dollars to to
have a kind of infrastructure that
allows for rapid publication rapid
access to information in fact you know
people really forget that you know if
there was some decrease in cost of
publishing and better access to
information
so forth it doesn't happen magically
it's actually a fairly small return on a
massive investment that we've already
been making in the early 80s also we saw
the beginnings of sequence databases and
certain principles of open access and
international data sharing also started
then so the sequence databases you can
imagine our sort of all open access
people can take all the data they can
they can sell it in different ways they
can do all kinds of things with it you
can get GenBank data from NCBI for free
but you can get that same data from
companies from other academic groups and
so forth so there's a lot of diversity
there in 1988 Congress established NCBI
and that was really at the beginning
periods of the Human Genome Project and
and and we've so we've been involved
kind of at the interface of of the
molecular data and and the online
literature for right from the beginning
and 97 pubmed was launched by Vice
President Gore as a free free access of
web-based bibliographic database it
really grew out of our understanding
that if we were going to make the
sequence data available it was useful to
have the associated abstracts from the
papers also available and then we
realized it was useful to have papers
that were similar on the similar subject
available and then after that we thought
might as well make it all freely
available as you probably know medline
was available before that but it wasn't
pretty ok so the road to PubMed Central
has always been a bit rocky but it
started off in a very interesting way
harold varmus and Pat Brown were eating
at the Tassajara bakery cafe and
discussing new ways of getting
information out and and some of the
potentials that high-throughput biology
and genomics had and how it could be
sort of held back because the literature
itself was balkanized and wasn't freely
available in the same way as the
sequence data at about the same time
there was a meeting at the Banbury
center
it was a genome project workshop and
there was a separate period set aside to
discuss open access publishing Paul
Ginsberg who is in charge of the physics
archive was there and it was a very
spirited discussion that I had the
privilege of being part of which and
included senior scientists graduate
students some computer type folks
experimentalists and and actually also
the the publisher of the Cold Spring
Harbor press who was actually kind of
blown away by the level of discontent
with a current status quo in publishing
I can remember the look on his face as
the discussion kind of heated up even
more and I that's going to think he
enjoyed it in in May of 99 dr. Varmus
proposed the e biomed project he sent a
letter fairly widely which described a
bunch of ideas which were just sort of
churning around then they really weren't
there wasn't a sort of a fixed plan at
the time but it it was done in a way
that got tremendous reaction from the
publishers and I think was unfortunate
that it kind of went out that way but he
thought that that it was going to be
good to stir things up and he did there
was some ideas that were very ambitious
and very different including an idea
that NIH grantees would be able to
rapidly publish papers as long as they
were communicated by two other grantees
this this made a lot of press but
nothing happened for a little while
because of all the excitement and then
in February 2000 bet central was
launched the earliest journals in there
were the proceedings and Nash cadmea
science is molecular biology of the cell
and the idea behind this archive was
that if a publisher wanted to have their
content archived we would do it for free
we would keep it available in general
they would give us content that was at
least a few months or a year old so
wouldn't
act on subscriptions and frankly the
people involved thought it was a good
thing that the publishers especially the
society publishers would buy into it
although we were wrong most of them
really were very nervous about it a
little bit after that biomed central was
started it was a commercial for profit
company started by vtec crotch he
created to create open access journals
and fairly recently that was sold to
Springer and and vtec made a fair amount
of money out of that and I think that
that's a vindication of his notion that
in fact open access publishing could be
done in a profitable way now we see that
plus one and some of the other plus
journals are also highly profitable and
again shows that this can be a
sustaining way of publishing science in
2002 harold varmus Pat Brown and my
giessen from Berkeley established the
public library of science as an online
publisher so the philosophy behind
pubmed central was number one it was
quite consistent with the National
Library of medicines general mandate as
a National Library to choir organize
preserve and disseminate the results of
our medical research but to extend that
to the electronic literature which as
you know it's a real challenge for
libraries now that in the past when you
had print you could archive it in your
library now much of the content is
available electronically and you're only
getting a subscription and the libraries
can't actively play a role in archiving
the idea would be in PubMed Central that
you would have free and unrestricted
access to the material and it would be
integrated with all the other online
information and because the way we used
the information would change over time
that was very important to have it as an
open archive so that you could keep
curating and finding issues with how
you've mapped the information into the
digital format and the library had found
actually from medline for many years
that the best way to ensure that the
electronic content was in a usable form
was to actually keep using it in a lot
of different ways so that was an
important
back to it so back in the beginning the
only way content would get into PubMed
Central was that a publisher would
voluntarily offer to to to participate
they would sign an agreement the
copyright would be retained by the
publisher or the author depending on how
that content came in beginning NLM would
have a non-exclusive perpetual use
license for the content generally there
would be free access within 12 months of
publication of those some of the
journals actually had it available
immediately the journal could stop
depositing could get out of the
agreement at any time but the content
that was already in would stay available
now while PubMed Central has been
associated with open access movement in
fact the true open access articles are
only a fraction of the content in PubMed
Central most of the content does have
restrictions that are imposed by either
the publisher or the other copyright
holder currently pubmed central also is
a repository for author manuscripts
that's the form of the paper which has
gone through all peer review and all the
revisions due to peer review and and
that is often what is the what is
supposed to be deposited under various
funding agency mandatory deposition
policies so NIH has one of these
policies after year Wellcome Trust and
other UK funders have it after six
months Howard Hughes six months the
Canadian Institutes of Health Research
also have these policies and now a
growing number of private foundations
have mandatory deposition rules which is
if you get money from us then after some
period of time the content has to be
freely available in PubMed Central we
use the same digital infrastructure for
the archiving of books and other
documents such as practice guidelines so
one of the ideas from the beginning was
to a cross-linked the literature with
the underlying molecular databases and
other databases so the figure in this
paper is just a picture of small
molecules but because we can mine out
information about this in map it to the
small molecule database we can actually
map this paper
and the compounds in this to our
compound database and in this case this
isn't just a picture we actually have
the secondary structure of the molecule
and can compute similar chemicals and do
a variety of other computations on it
and we can connect it also to the
protein structure database because the
protein structures when they come we can
mine out the chemical ligands that are
often co crystallized with them and and
that way connect as well so these sorts
of connections can be useful and I'll
talk a little bit about how we currently
use that and how we hope to in the
future pubmed central has also become
international actually we always thought
it would have to be international that's
our experience with all the other
molecular databases we work on right now
there's a center in canada and in the UK
and the idea would be that the legal
agreements would be between the
publishers and then LM and n LM would
have agreements with other archives and
all of this has to be consistent it can
be a little bit of a bother at times but
most of that is flowing along fairly
smoothly the idea is to protect the
copyright and the integrity of the
content and also satisfy the publisher
standards for way the articles are
presented and to provide consistent
reporting of usage data so all of the
usage data can be aggregated for the
publishers who are participating I'm
going to skip them multiple archiving
centers it's pretty obvious that the
content is safer if it's available in
more different places but but there's
also other reasons to have multiple
archives especially with the biomedical
literature because the use of that
interfaces with the educational system
of different countries and with the
healthcare system of different countries
which differ more than for example the
way people use DNA sequences in America
and DNA sequences in Europe I mean they
reuse them pretty similarly but but but
the actual natural language content we
do use differently one aspect of PubMed
Central which was pushed very strong by
the first group of advisors that we had
the we have a formal advisory group was
to go back and for the journals that are
participating digitized as much of the
content as we could and we done that as
a collaboration with the Wellcome Trust
and the UK joint information systems
committee
and and fours many of the journals that
are participating that we can we've gone
back and and and digitized the content
and we think that's been a very
successful project we can see that that
content is used quite a bit and it goes
back really quite far and one of the
things I won't experience my own
research is that I'm ending up using
research that goes back to the 60s and
70s and say bacteriology that I never
would have found otherwise and and I
think it's unfortunate when you look you
can see that people have rediscovered
things multiple times because they
didn't have easy access to the older
literature as a side point we always
felt that it would be most useful if we
mapped all of these different journals
their content which would be in
different formats into a single common
archival format after an initial
experience trying to do this we
developed an XML DTD for journals we did
that a second phase of that in
cooperation with the mellon Foundation a
journal archiving program and made this
public in 2003 it's a it's a flexible
format the the content is supplied and a
variety of source d tds and then we can
map it into the archiving DTD we also
came up with a publishing DTD a digital
specification for the format which is
more restrictive and that's for groups
that want to start authoring the content
and an XML DTD approximately seventy
percent of the articles coming to pubmed
central now are from sources that are
already using this DTD so it's really
become somewhat of a standard it was
agreed by the Library of Congress
British Library to make it a common
standard for journal articles and other
countries are taking it on and a number
of the commercial vendors are also using
the NLM DTD well this is something that
we found true for pubmed central and
actually true for most of our databases
which is that as the content as the the
database gets more comprehensive the
usage goes up approximately
proportionally and this is
true for molecular databases and it's
also turning out to be true for pubmed
central that the archive is more useful
and therefore used more as it gets more
comprehensive and that i think was one
of the motivations for doctors a--honey
and for Congress to get involved in
making some aspects of the program no
longer voluntary but mandatory so before
public access you could do a search of
Google and for example find a paper on
tumor biomarkers and then go to PubMed
and and see that this is work that's
funded by NIH and then you try to get it
and you find out that you have to pay
money for it and I you know this sounds
like a little story but when when pubmed
central first started i can remember
getting a phone call from my dad one
evening and he was at a friend's house
and at about five or six of his buddies
all of whom were fairly old at the time
and they were looking up something about
prostate cancer and they were using
PubMed one of them was clever enough and
they were using the system and they
found a paper and they wanted to get
more information this true story I can
remember telling this to some publishers
they didn't like it but my dad said it
says that it's funded by NIH but when i
try to get the paper I can't get the
paper to tell me I have to spend thirty
or forty bucks I can't remember what it
was and you know we just want to use the
paper what's wrong and I had to explain
to him that just because nih-funded the
work and just because we can get you to
the paper the way it works is the
publisher owns that paper in fact you
could do a query in pubmed and get a
whole bunch of papers that are funded by
NIH and only one of them might be
available for free in PubMed Central and
so in December 26 of 2007 Congress made
the public access essentially if you've
got NIH funding you had to make sure
your paper was available in PubMed
Central within a year of publication
there was a freely available within a
year it would be put in submitted at the
time of acceptance and in 2009 this was
a made up permanent policy
I would like to say that a hundred
percent of the papers are going in now
right now we're at probably around
sixty-five percent compliance rate a
number of steps are going to be taken
over the next year that I think will
move us up to closer to a hundred
percent I think NIH's really tried to
kind of take a light hand with this but
by the times it becomes apparent that
they have to step that up forward
publishers who are artists access
are not going to laugh their entire lazy
publish papers
so so the policy applies to all papers
that were coming out of research that
was funded back back here okay and so
research that was funded before this
does not it does not apply all right so
yeah I think even if we even if we can
make the future look better with that
being in there there's still going to be
a lot of old content that that won't be
freely available I'm going to switch
gears a little bit here and talk briefly
about what we call our discovery
initiative because it was also one of
the motivations really for pushing more
with public access so this was motivated
because we we found that that there were
a million ways to improve pages and our
website nothing was right really in my
opinion everything could be improved and
we would sometimes put a lot of work
into improving something and then I
would look at what they didn't I thought
why did we prioritize that why did we do
that what was the goal of that it would
be much easier if we had something like
Amazon or we were like Google where all
we're talking about is a simple
objective function clicking on an ad or
buying something here you know what what
could we do and and what what became
apparent was that we could take
advantage of a paradox that most users
are not curious most users do not pick
up rocks and see what's underneath them
if they don't see something interesting
to them on a page they don't click on
anything that's it that's that's a
challenge the good side of that is that
if you do find them clicking on things
generally speaking it's because they
found an interesting or useful now you
can follow that up with interviews and
do other kinds of studies but we found
that to be absolutely as I say it's a
it's a double-edged sword on the one
hand it makes it harder to get people to
good information on the other hand it
allows you to see when you're when
you're improving because people won't do
three clicks to get some place if you
don't make it very easy for them they
won't go
and so our bottom line has to be
something simple and I call it
discoveries it's basically we need to
improve the quantity and quality and the
relevance of the information obtained
and viewed by our users and we need to
be able to wherever possible see that by
studying our web logs so we can design
sites in the beginning with interviews
we can go back and ask users questions
but in the end we have to really make
sure that we delivered and we see a
change a quantitative change in how
people are using our system so we do you
want to interview users but we focus
also on iterating constantly developing
a quantitative picture of how people are
using our site and then modify what
we're doing and then sing if that's
working better all right now it turns
out that it is not easy to do this it's
not intuitive and we're still struggling
with it but we can make we've made
quantitative easy to prove examples of
this and sometimes our users are not
even aware when we've made a change in
the system and we can see that that a
certain fraction of the users are doing
better with it so one thing you can see
and this is true for many sites this
data is no one correct for our site but
it doesn't really matter you can treat
this as an abstract if you wish that
that typically with any kind of search
system people will do a search and
sometimes they'll click right away but
sometimes they modify the search as soon
as they see the results and then they'll
find the click something or sometimes
they'll go back and do three different
searches and they'll click and you see a
distribution it looks like this and
different search systems depending on
how well they work will have different
decay curves like that but that also
tells you that your query logs have a
lot of useful information in them
because people are typing inquiries and
then you can see do they click or not
what's happening what did they actually
type what's the similarity of the
queries to each other and so you can
mine the query logs in useful ways and
and one way to do that is through
determining related queries basically
over here we have also try all right now
we have a drop-down that actually sort
of steals the fraction of users that use
this but this is based on on looking at
that are more specific than the user's
query and and that match it well and and
and these become suggested queries that
that might be better for the user than
this and we find is that that related
queries ad has worked very well we get a
click-through rate of over six percent
with that now as I say we the drop-down
more of our users are using that and so
the number of people who end up having
to use the the related queries ad is
less but it's using the same kind of
information so this is kind of thing
that we do with everything now on our
site it takes a while to work through
all the pages and to keep revisiting
things another example is for the
nucleotide database if you look at the
query logs you see that a lot of the
queries that users are making really
would be better if they were queries in
the genes database that information is
more curated and it's more organized and
if you're using a gene name as a query
it's probably a better place to go and
so we put this little ad at the top here
that if you're looking for gene
information you might want to click
there and and what we find I've switched
already but what we find is a very high
fraction it started off at about
fourteen percent now I think it's almost
twenty-five percent of our users of this
database click through to the gene add
all right because it's been a better
place for them to go and what was
interesting is in the beginning was
about fifteen percent and then over time
that rate went up this is the citation
matcher that this has a very high
click-through rate let's see I didn't
put that down I think it's something
like 28 or 29 percent and it's just a
matter of us improving the citation
matcher and we will be improving over
the next couple months because we see
how often it's used we want to get as
many queries where if they look like
they were trying to do citation matching
get that to trigger so now right now in
our system we're trying to develop
sensors and refine the sensors for
disease names for gene names for drug
names for citations for a variety of
other things and then even though the
basic query handling
the query may work one way we're
automatically firing off many other
types of queries and seeing can we do a
better match that's basically the way
Google does their system there's a
pretty good article recently in Wired
magazine about how Google's search
system works obviously they do in a more
sophisticated manner than us they have a
lot more the infrastructure and so forth
but that basic approach is really what
you have to do you have to try lots of
guesses at once see what the results are
and then decide how to present all of
these different ways of viewing a query
and present it back to the user there's
no magic algorithm in fact Google a lot
of people think well it's PageRank that
Google uses actually Google doesn't even
use pay page rank at all anymore or
barely at all so we we have a dashboard
that we keep adding different kinds of
tracking tools to various things that
we're doing and seeing how they're
working sometimes you fix one thing and
it works better but it makes something
else not work as well people don't use
it as much or there's something degraded
there and so we have to keep track of it
all every week or two we have a meeting
of all the senior people in the group
with the people in charge of the web log
analysis project and we go over various
reports and discuss new things to
analyze and so forth so it's a lot of
fun it's very challenging it turns out
most people even if they're smart folks
and good in other areas turn out not to
be so good at analyzing web logs it's it
it you have to sort of be like Sherlock
Holmes because you'll see something
you'll try to figure out what does it
mean then you have to sort of test if
that were true then we should see
something else happen and it gets very
complex very quickly but then when you
get something right it's amazingly it's
really a lot of fun because all of a
sudden you see wow we got that one right
your numbers really pick up because if
you have a couple million users you
really can get good statistics we've
changed the look of PubMed Central we've
gotten some good feedback on it we also
some show links down below but one of
the questions we need to ask ourselves
is how should this look best on an
iPhone because we definitely have
requests for that and so we're looking
at how can we make a reasonable view of
full text and an iphone what about for
those people have very wide screen Mon
on their desk is there a better view is
there a better presentation of the
content that way perhaps for example all
the figures in one scrollable window in
and the text and the other that way you
can be keeping your the figure that
you're interested in on the screen at
all times and look at other stuff and so
how we do this is we talk to various
users we get their ideas we mock up
certain things we get back get their
feedback again then we start to do
testing and piloting it's a lot of fun
it never goes as fast as you'd like but
but I think you can make progress that
way all right so last bid on this right
now we have almost two million articles
in PubMed Central the journal accounts
well actually there's one point nine
plus million articles and the total
items including issue covers table of
contents and so forth is over two
million we have 585 active titles that
are in full participation in other words
all the articles go into PubMed Central
and the NIH portfolio those are
publishers that only give us the content
if it was authored as part of the NIH
public access policy we have 200 plus
titles there and selective deposit are
from though primarily commercial
publishers we're like Springer for
example has a policy author open choice
or whatever so if the author pays then
that content is automatically deposited
quick change here and then I'll take
questions in many ways the although open
access is a positive and so forth I
think the returns on on the investment
with all the IT and so forth have not
been as dramatics we'd like for academic
communication for communicating
scientific knowledge certainly in terms
of the cost journals are more and more
expensive textbooks are more and more
expensive still much of the content is
not as broadly available as you'd like
just think of the small biotech
companies around this country they can't
get it almost any of the content it's
way too expensive for them to to get
subscriptions to everything the other
problem that I think is even more
important is that it takes so long to
publish a paper even in an open access
journal even in plus one
and it's such a bother you know you so
many of us experience up in you send a
paper off to the referees like it one
says they want this they want that you
go back and forth eventually maybe end
up having to go to another journal it
can take nine months to publish a paper
that it only took you maybe a month or
so to actually do the underlying work
even worse than that is that cause it's
so much work to get a paper out the door
and communicated a lot of people are
simply not publishing work little
discoveries which they don't see is
important enough to put that much time
into and so a lot of discoveries just
never get published and then they're
rediscovered as needed often these are
the things that are the most sort of
hard very very straightforward very
objective data but because they're not
really part of the main research area of
the scientist they just don't bother
with it so this is this has been very
costly it would be great to be able to
publish just as easy in science or
almost as easy because we do want peer
review as it is to do a blog or to be on
some group site or whatever and I think
scientists have a kind of a split
mentality now you know they somebody can
go on Wikipedia and see something they
think is wrong and make a change or they
can have a blog or whatever have some
idea and get it out the door but with
their own research it's very very slow
so it would be great if we had an
approach that we could have almost
something like a blog anybody can be an
author we can get feedback from readers
and reviewers but we had peer review as
well so actually there is an option for
that right now that we've been playing
around with we've been using the google
null authoring system because of the
pandemic in spring i contacted the folks
at plus and at Google and suggest that
we tried to do a new kind of journal it
would be very rapid turnaround that
would do screening to make sure by
experts in the field that the content
was find that the experimental methods
were solid and so forth but would be
fast and essentially what what we do is
we use something than
all system where you author on the
server you actually compose the paper on
the server your profile your Google
profile contains all of your affiliation
and other metadata you invite your
co-authors their metadata and so forth
is connected to the paper and you just
press a button to submit it everything
is there all the figures and if it's
accepted it gets gets a peer-reviewed if
it's accepted you press a button it's
immediately available and the next day
pubmed central gets the xml content
because google has worked with us to
have an output of the system that's
already structured so the system has
fairly simple tools for online that and
it could be nice if they were a bit
richer they may be increasing some of
the richness of them but it's enough to
do papers that look okay there's a sort
of a simple citation reference manager
in it where you can put in pubmed ids
and it'll generate your your references
or you can cut and paste them in from
some other source you upload your
figures in a variety of image formats
and you can control the placement and
the size and the way it appears to users
but from the point of view of archiving
when we get it we actually get the full
resolution figure and the legend and so
forth attached to it and that all is
tagged appropriately and then you just
press a button when it's ready to submit
and off it goes here's an example of a
paper on the Google site there's some
aspects that look like a standard paper
if we were to scroll down you could see
that in some aspects that are a little
bit different you have the pictures of
people I found it really interesting in
the beginning when we started this we
now have about 60 articles or so in
there people wouldn't have a picture at
all of themselves you just see a sort of
a cartoon empty box and then you started
to see some very stiff pictures and then
you saw some other pictures there was
one graduate student who was kind of
funny to watch the the evolution of the
pictures until there was a kind of a
very traumatic miss fashion model
picture there's another person who keeps
changing their picture because this is
just linked to the google profile and
and so we sort of get a sense of of what
they're doing with their life as they go
but anyway watching the sociological
aspects of this isn't
so how can you start a new journal with
a system essentially you define a scope
and the approach you want to do for peer
review you recruit other chief editors
in a court of a standing group of of
relevant peer reviewers and then you can
set the journal up on for example this
google null site and if you provide a
description of the journal and the goals
and the and all of that and who's on the
masthead and so forth to the NLM
collections committee it's possible that
that would be considered for inclusion
in the annalynne collection and
therefore would be available in PubMed
Central and in pubmed and so then you
can have archiving and everything else
so that's what's happened with +
currents influenza there's another
journal ready to start from a group of
french researchers the CDC is going to
be announcing a systematic reviews
journal using this and plus is now
talking about expanding + currents
influenza into a number of other areas
there's also very large a funding agency
in another country that's looking at
starting a couple journals using this
knowledge system and again focusing on
aspects like rapid peer-review
post-publication peer review as well and
and I think hopefully we'll start to see
this really take off these are the folks
that work on our digital publishing
efforts including pubmed central there's
sega krasnoff who's he's done a great
job running in and let's see Jeff Beck
over here who beekeeper and the master
of XML and it's just a great crew to
work with we've been really lucky to
have a stable group working on the
project so I'm ready thank you very much
any questions
I'm just wondering if you could talk
about the process by which an old
journal is considered for inclusion in n
alone so the the NLM has a mandate to
collect an archive the literature and so
what what they want to be able to do
with the new journalists decide is it in
scope is it you know what is the is
there an explicit policy in terms of how
the peer review is being done who the
people involved with it and so forth and
then they also actually want to see on
the order of a dozen articles in some
cases for example if it's a publisher
like Plus which already has a track
record maybe only a half dozen articles
or whatever might be necessary if it's
just a group of academics not associated
with a publisher they want to see more
articles and then they look at and they
also do ask for input from other folks
to see whether it looks like these you
know this is a reasonable and then and
then that's that so largely it's fairly
inclusive this is not the same as being
you know chosen for indexing for mesh
indexing and pubmed that could happen
downstream which requires more articles
and an outside review but so this is
fairly lightweight
as the content in PubMed Central
increases are there any plans to index
that full text of that searchable sort
of the way Google Scholar allows you to
search across the text rather than just
the abstract and the mesh associated XML
that's a good question so actually the
full text is searchable now but I would
not say that we're that happy with our
approach the full text retrieval it's
been a lot of studies done comparing
retrieval of just the abstracts and mesh
terms and so forth versus the full text
what you can show is if you're using a
really good approach searching the full
text is a little bit better but
surprisingly not that much better and
and so were we are working on that I
mean you already can do it if you search
directly in pubmed central post to
pubmed what we're working on is actually
incorporating more the information from
pubmed central into the PubMed search so
that at least for the articles that we
have the full text there's other things
we can get and it's not just in terms of
retrieval it's also in terms of what you
show the user so when you if so we're
moving to create a image database with
all of the figures that are in our books
and in PubMed Central and separately
searching that as well as these other
things because maybe in fact what's
really most useful to you is seeing a
particular figure and that's the way I
know that is what I want that's got what
I want and so if you really look at
being in Google whatever you learn a lot
about why they're doing certain things
you want to have a separate image
database and you want to be searching
that all the time and have certain
tricks work there certain statistical
text retrieval for that show people some
of that maybe you're lucky that you
actually showed them directly what they
wanted but maybe what you've done is
trigger their mind to think actually
i'll switch and just press the button to
see just the image search and so we're
moving in that direction incorporating
image searching and full-text searching
and our book searching a subset of the
books will be getting pubmed abstracts
and will be in pubmed now certainly
things like the practice guidelines
books that where they really designed
them from the beginning was sort of like
a little abstract and so forth per
chapter that's going to be in in the
PubMed search you'll be able to turn
that off and you'll be able to
distinguish when you're doing the search
but that's going to be fairly soon
that's actually going to be within a
matter of weeks that that'll be in the
search as well any other questions
we're anxious at our institution to find
out if we can through PubMed Central
track our institutions open access
articles search it periodically every
month or every however often and I'm
going to list a full list of our open
access articles we try to do something
through PubMed with a strategy that we
were given by the NLM helpdesk the
PubMed help desk but it's not picking up
everything right so we've done a little
experiment with the folks at harvard
medical school to provide something for
them and see how that works and most
likely when we're confident and they're
confident that seems to be working we'll
we'll try to extend that i do think it's
likely that nih will be contacting the
offices responsive research to let them
know what articles are out of compliance
and get their assistance and making sure
that that that those get in and there's
other things that we're working on two
projects that overlap one is called my
bibliography which already exists but is
being generalized so that authors can
easily update kind of keep electronic
bibliography on our system for the pub
med records but also for book chapters
or patents or whatever else and an hour
author ID project which will involve
computational disambiguation once you
have one of these my bibliography if you
did a paper and you didn't enter it into
your bibliography you'll get oh is this
your paper do you want to include that
and then you can get that printed out in
various ways but you can also have that
if your institution is interested have
automatic reporting where the author
says okay I want that stuff to go to the
institution in that that can that can
provide structured reports for you so
there'll be a number of ways for
institutions to use the information but
I mean I think in the end you know
there's sort of different populations of
researchers who are funded and some of
them are more resistant than others but
I think that they'll move along you know
when if
officer sponsored research contacts them
i think they'll be more responsive
chances are at some point nih may end up
having to say to somebody GI we you're
funded you're great but you're not going
to get your funds until your articles
are in and i think just a few examples
of that and people will be more
responsive I was wondering what you
could tell us about what it took
politically to get the appropriations
bill passed so I'm not a politician what
I would say is that it has always been
the case that actually Congress was
ahead of NIH in terms of wanting this
policy so starting way back there have
been efforts in Congress to push to have
more access or open access actually even
at times of NIH funded content and so
while there has been a lot of back and
forth when publishers were upset about
it and they would tell the staffers
things we'd have to go to them and
explain no this is this is actually how
we see it or these are the facts as we
know them and so forth so there has been
back and forth that way but most of the
most of the initiative really for the
policy at all stages has come from
Congress it's not too surprising it's
kind of a no-brainer unless you're in a
district where a publisher is very
active the fact is that Congress is
already spending the money on the
research it's kind of a easy gift to
your state to make sure the content is
freely available and they are actually
hearing from their librarians the state
universities and so forth that
increasingly the leading universities
and certainly smaller universities and
colleges are not having access to
federally funded research so it's really
not be an NIH that's led the half that
kind of led this as much as I would have
liked to see all the papers freely
available in whatever else that's not
really been it's not really been the NIH
position it's really more come from both
librarians some of the politicians who
have been contact by their librarians
and or other advocacy
oops and and just a number of the
staffers who kind of understood how this
was going and really wanted to push it
through I would you happen to have some
schematic that shows how you can limit a
search do you have a advanced search
that wasn't going to so you can narrow
it down to NIH articles full text
timeframes I'm not the best at demoing
the system because I have fairly
idiosyncratic way of using it but there
is a filter right on the PubMed search
page to just get free full text and that
would include not just the free text
articles in PubMed Central but also the
articles that are free available on the
publisher site so if one of the issues
is that you want to just get the free
articles right on the front of the
PubMed page when you do a search there's
a little thing on the right that allows
you to just get the free articles
can we be sure that all the articles
deposited in the PubMed Central as a
final versions or there may be some
discrepancy between the version in
PubMed Central and commercially
published article well I think that the
the tack that was taken on the issue was
that that the version of the article
which the US government felt was most
obviously one that they could claim
control over was the author's final
manuscript which is the one prior to
copy editing and that's the one that
that they pushed for if a publisher
decides to participate in PubMed Central
for those articles then the final
published article is in PubMed Central
but otherwise I think for a variety of
reasons and I don't know if they were
primarily legal reasons or you know sort
of balancing off things with the
publishers they decided to just push for
the author final manuscript I have to
say that well authors don't like the
fact that they end up having to follow
up in terms of checking their their
manuscript which we tagged and so forth
in terms of the users we haven't gotten
a lot of complaints or problems every
once awhile there's been an article that
an author feels there were substantial
changes made in copy editing and they
like you know that they that there's
some awkwardness but has not been that's
not been as much of an issue as some
people felt it would be
okay well thank you very much